Ryan is with us in clarksville hey Ryan
how are you I am doing great in yourself
Dave better than I deserve what's up hey
so really the heart of my question you
know is buying versus renting and I
understand a lot of what you teach and
I've been following you for about two
years now is behavioral behavioral but
I'd kind of like to walk you through the
numbers so about two years ago my wife
and I had about 77,000 in debt we went
from we had our first child when from
two incomes to one income and since
about two years ago we had 77,000 we've
got 22,000 left we're about to finish
maybe step 2 now awesome tip and then
this last September we made the decision
to get out of the army we've been in for
seven years now as we're going to make
the transition so starting this past
September we put baby set two on hold to
save up a larger emergency fund not
knowing kind of what the job looks like
afterwards well I just accepted a job
down in Jacksonville a few weeks ago so
we've got about 20,000 saved up also
22,000 left in debt so we're about to be
debt-free yeah and then the question is
exactly very excited
it is renting versus buying when we're
going to Jacksonville I kind of looked
at the numbers and what the numbers say
is you know if I we get a VA loan we're
able to start saving for retirement and
get our three to six month emergency
fund established in September of 2017
whereas if we rent looking at the rent
rates we're not able to save for the 20%
down if we do with maybe step 3b and buy
a house until about September of 2019 so
the question is do we buy now and get
that extra the way I see there's two
positives there's equity we'd get in the
house plus I start saving for retirement
two years ahead of time when I move into
baby steps four and six at the same time
for the fact that you're moving in a
house broke yeah which is just so
dangerous it's unbelievable you're
asking for trouble and the VA loans are
more expensive loan anyway
it's not a bargain it's the worst loan
out there as far as the three VA FHA and
conventional conventionals the cheapest
FHA next and VA last the only reason
anyone ever does a VA loan is because
they don't have any money hmm
and you can get a nothing down deal with
that that's the only reason anybody uses
their VA loan thank you for your service
to the country by the way now I would
rent the only thing I would adjust is
where you're renting I think you're
comparing rental properties you wouldn't
rent than the same place you would buy
internal clocks same neighborhood when
you rent your buying patience so you
rent the cheapest possible thing and so
you're probably in a different area when
you rent than you would buy in which
accelerates the time that you do that
but I want you to get you know finish up
your debts which you're not going to be
quite debt-free is what you've described
to me and then finish that up and then
get your emergency fund in place a lot
of times the first-time homebuyers in a
situation like your end doesn't save the
entire 20% and so I might I might back
off on that get but get five or ten
percent something like that down and
just do a conventional loan and it's
going to be cheaper you're going to pick
up PMI but you can get the PMI kicked
off when you get it paid down to 80%
okay when you get it paid down I mean
you're not going to keep you know what
you're not going to keep the PMI the
entire life of the mortgage it's just
for the number of years until you get it
paid down and then that gets you on into
retirement probably at about the same
schedule you were talking about because
you got a factor in the numbers with my
change in this was cheaper rent and not
a full 20% down okay and when I put
those two things together it tightens
this calendar back up in you in what
you're describing but I just I've seen
so many folks buy a home broke and it
just it makes them broker man it just
becomes the house is not a blessing it's
a curse then yeah I just don't want that
to happen to you yeah and the other
thing I was looking at everything that
I've looked at is my bare minimum salary
so my salary is going to be 85 and then
I have the option my wife is not working
we've heard for her to stay home she's
got a nursing degree she can work a
little bit and then if I take my GI
benefits and
to school while I'm working as well
that's X or 1500 a month oh yeah that
Jackson everything you get that stipend
going and the good news about nursing is
she's got all kinds of flexibility she
doesn't have to do a nine-to-five and
throw the kids in daycare I mean she can
pick up some you know pick up a couple
of 12s a week and really change your
whole picture dramatically right and
then and everything that I looked at
whenever I was kind of looking
forecasted I'd like to go off I like to
remove as much risk heated up and not
counting on that extra in case you were
working on worse case scenario on
everything yeah but that changes the
numbers too so I mean bottom line is
you're probably renting for about a year
with what you're describing there okay
and with me backing off the 20 with the
first time homebuyer down to maybe five
or ten down okay that kind of thing I
think you know if you start piling on
some extra income and you guys tighten
it up and you rent cheaper you're
probably written for about a year
something like that and then you buy and
then you move on out and get your
retirement going you're going to do
great what's your new job in an
Operations management position the only
the other this is not a money thing but
it's kind of at that time
the position I got hired on they're
looking for me to move up in position in
about five years which would mean you
know into a general management position
of the facility that's wonderful
that's a great place that's a great
track right out of the military very
well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim